remember how we talked about actually
writing code to do intersection between
two rectangles we've actually abstracted
that away and actually turned it into a
function inside of gmaps you can call
gmap.intersectrect the is visible
function is actually a nice little
helper that'll pass in the viewrect and
the rectangle for this tile into the
intersect direct function to determine
whether or not this tile is visible to
the current view rectangle this is a
helpful little function that we'll
utilize in a couple different places
moving forward now before moving forward
let's go ahead and write this intersect
rect function so that it takes two
rectangles with top bottom left and
right values and returns whether or not
they intersect